I know CBS MacGyver hasn't no sweat
figuring out how to stop a hail of
bullets he just uses physics to find out
how much paper he needs to stack hey
this is a paper that's all we need to
stop a bullet now I don't know if the
star of MacGyver actually studied
physics back in high school but our poor
Candace had learned a lot about the
Georgia native because Lucas Hill is
going home with 80
every time I come home basically I just
bring my mom here sort of her favorite
restaurants so you're really sweet to
your mom correct
yeah make a point to say that in front
of your dad
hello game home here is Marietta Georgia
this is my mom this is my little brother
brother Nick is 8 years younger with the
resemblance here can we just take a sit
also there Lucas as manager Tom and his
high school friend Justin well speaking
of high school earlier in the day Lucas
visited his alma mater
Carlton Cal high school just a few miles
away and took us along oh this is
embarrassing now there we go this is
principal's office spent a lot of time
in there we're gonna go down to the
German room the German teacher is Justin
whom we met at lunch and high school
they were German students together hung
to the clapper ha ha ha ha no I told me
to shut up oh man that was a loser look
at that loser right there were you that
the smooth talker the confident guy is
not at all even if I wanted attention
girls will give it dropping by tills
original German teacher mr. Gordon uh
yeah skip nickel that very first year of
course I remember oh you've got a you've
got a student who's in the movies in the
Johnny Cash movie that's right Lucas
played young Johnny Cash's brother Jack
and walk the line well so when did you
know that you wanted to be in actors I
think was 10
really didn't who didn't have anything
to do because they didn't play sports
Wow most likely to be famous my students
it's weird they all know every time is
his name comes up they know him they go
that was Hannah Montana's boyfriend in
the movie and he was in the Taylor Swift
music video so you went to the prom you
did this I did not go to prom you didn't
have that problem how can everyone to
anything where Lucas did go back in the
day video production class and this is
the best room to play video games
because coach Heron couldn't see you and
now that he's starring as Angus MacGyver
Lucas is definitely too cool for school
what is the biggest perk of having him
as a brother to tell girls though and
while he didn't get the girl in high
school mom Dana still has hope what kind
of girl would you like for your for your
son oh one that makes him happy yeah
solid answer you hear that I really
enjoyed this yeah baby going on mama
knows best
well that's cuz it leaves a big pool out
there